[تصفيق]
عندما وصلت إلى تشيلي
شعرت وكأنني قطعة أحجية مفقودة، قطعة
ضائعة منذ 42 عامًا،
إنها حفلة عيد ميلاد كان عليها الانتظار
لأكثر من أربعة عقود، لقد سرقوا 42
عامًا لكنهم لن يسرقوا 43 عامًا
يحتفل جيمي ليوبارد تيتان مع
عائلة لم يكن يعلم بوجودها من قبل. أنا
محظوظ لأن لدي
عائلة محبة على جانبي خط الاستواء.
تبدأ قصته في عام 1981 في فالديفيا، وهي مدينة
في جنوب تشيلي، والدتي وأمي التي
أعطتها.  لقد ولدتني قبل موعد ولادتي بشهر واحد،
قالوا لها، تعلمين أنه يبدو
مصابًا باليرقان، تعلمين أنه يبدو أصفر اللون،
علينا أن نضعه في الحاضنة، وقد
أخرجوني من هناك قبل أن تتمكن من احتضاني
قبل أن تسميني، لقد
حملوني
خارجًا  ثم عادوا وأخبروها
أنني مت. يقول تيتان إن الأمر
كله كان مخططًا لكسب المال من
العائلات الأجنبية المطمئنة التي تتطلع إلى
تبني الأطفال، وخاصة الأمريكيين الذين
ليس لديهم أي فكرة عما يحدث
لعائلتك بالتبني في الولايات المتحدة.
لم يكن لديهم أي فكرة عن تعرضك للسرقة عندما كنت
طفلاً، ولم يصدقوا ولو لثانية واحدة أنهم
كانوا يشترون طفلاً، ولم
يكونوا ليفعلوا ذلك أبدًا خلال
دكتاتورية الجنرال أوغستو
بينوشيه في السبعينيات والثمانينيات من القرن الماضي، حيث
تم نقل الأطفال إلى وكالات التبني، بعضهم
من  تم الاستيلاء على الطبقات العليا أو التخلي عنها
لحماية سمعة أمهاتهم
وبعض من الطبقات الدنيا حيث
سُرق الأطفال ببساطة.
تقول السلطات التشيلية إن العديد من الكهنة
والراهبات والأطباء والممرضات وغيرهم تآمروا
لتنفيذ عمليات تبني غير قانونية،
وأخبرتنا السلطات أن عددًا من الأطفال المسروقين يمكن أن
يكونوا  بالآلاف ولكن
التحقيق في حالات التبني قد
ضعف على مر السنين وأغلقت بعض
المستشفيات التي ولد فيها الأطفال
كما اكتشفنا
على مر السنين للعديد من النساء في هذا
البلد
ما
يعنيه هذا المستشفى في الأنقاض هو مكان  حيث
سُرق أطفالهم، وهو المكان الذي
أصبح كابوسًا بالنسبة لهم، حيث كانوا
يبحثون عن مكان
يلدون فيه طفلًا يتمتع بصحة جيدة بدلاً من ذلك، غادروا
خالي الوفاض،
ويقول إنه بعد أن اتصل بهم جيمي تيتان، أوصت
بإجراء اختبار الحمض النووي
مرحبًا بي.  الاسم هو جيمي تيتان عندما
عادت المباراة بعد بضعة أسابيع،
قالت إنها عرفت أن الخطوة التالية كانت إجراء
مكالمة هاتفية مع امرأة كانت لها الصدارة
لعقود من الزمن، وقد توفي ابنها بعد وقت قصير
من ولادتها،
ولم تصدق ذلك، كما قالت.
اعتقدت أنها مزحة سيئة الذوق
لأنها قيل لها إن
طفلها المولود قبل أوانه قد مات، ولم تكن تعلم
بأمري لأنني أُخذت منها عند ولادتي
وقيل لها إنني مت، وذلك عندما طلبت مني
أخبروها أنهم تخلصوا منه
ولذلك لم نحتضن بعضنا البعض أبدًا
ولم نعانق أبدًا
واليوم سأفعل ذلك لأول
مرة
بعد عدة أشهر مؤلمة
تمكن جيمي تيتان أخيرًا من السفر إليه
تشيلي
ستمنح ماريا أنجليكا غونزاليس
والدته البيولوجية الخنزير الذي كان عليه
الانتظار لمدة 42 عامًا. ماذا تريد أن
يعرف العالم عما حدث
لك؟ ماذا تريد أن يعرف الناس
عن قضيتك؟
أريدهم أن يعرفوا
أن هناك عشرات من  الآلاف من
الأطفال مثلي نروي قصتنا، ونجري
هذه المقابلات لأننا نروي هذه
القصص حتى يتم العثور على كل طفل،
كيف يمكنك استعادة الوقت الضائع،
لا يمكنك ذلك، يقول جيمي تيتان في النهاية
أضاف الحكمة حول ما حدث
جاءت من  إحدى بناته التي أخبرتهم
أنه لو لم يحدث شيء سيء لما
كانت هنا وبفضل ذلك
والدها الآن ليس لديه عائلة واحدة بل عائلتين
تحبه بشدة رافائيل رومو سي إن إن
سانتياغو تشيلي وأتلانتا